[Music]
well that's one did it to be honest so
yeah anyways what would you say
yeah so basically um yeah my file my dad
is night so he kicked me out the house
and then afterwards I stayed on my mates
house and then afterwards it's become
okay no it's much better than from
before cuz if I'm just gonna be somehow
you know this extremist terrorist and so
yeah what was your question you said so
my question was what made me yeah you
know you know but it was like oh I was
finger to myself like the lifestyle that
I was living here like me out so I just
fall back like you know life is just
about money cause bills and all that's
kind of stuff but what it is it's like
you know it's I had a got off like like
death around it's alright that was just
one part I'll just I wasn't I was just a
baby face yeah like for example my
cousin commits suicide
then he then he's me hanged himself in
the park like about few weeks after and
then my neighbor killed himself cause I
was madness was going on so it was just
that death was just like okay you know
just a reminder but then afterwards what
happened was obviously I'm chasing this
lifestyle that I want to be but and then
I met this guy he was quite wealthy he
had everything going for him you know
seemed not always depressed and he's
never happy I'm thinking to myself like
I want to be that you and you're here
just crying like they don't even have
you arrived
and I think I'm thinking like this
doesn't add up like so I was just
thinking you know I'll see that this
really happiness because you look at
laughter of a girl like rappers be you
know a rich people most I'm not the
depressed and they have to for them to
perform they have to take drugs to be on
stage it's all just question you know
what is really happiness you know and
then I'm just thinking about it and you
know it's just looking for your purpose
because if I if I said to you guys yeah
if you're in it on a train yeah and you
have or whatever you you're on this
plane you've got anything you want
everything yeah one at one point you're
going to ask yourself do you put me here
and where is this plane going yeah you
can ask yourself a question because one
said why put me on the spain and we're
not for my going so that's the question
that I would ask myself I'm stuck on
this earth who do policy and what am I
doing here
I didn't choose to look like this I
didn't choose my mom my dad my name my
brother my sister
this is same with everyone to give
Tennessee yeah so those things were
making me now to be curious in fact
making me wonder and then I would look
at Mike might be fun to you guys by
looking at my socks yeah I think seven
purpose yeah it's designed and it has a
purpose yeah so I'm thinking to myself
my stinky socks on purpose and there's
me and I'm designing this way you know
be it my eyes my hand my fingerprint
whatever it may be
like what's my purpose in life did I
just pop out you know so it was just
those things those elements in my life
will just not making me think a lot and
I always believed in high intelligence I
always believed those creator
you know yeah
yes discussing our show
do you think I would say the first thing
was in terms of their creator yeah you
can say that there is a crater but then
how do you define who the creature is
who you are you have a different
perspective on they actually and
therefore you'll have a different view
and also how do you differentiate from
you know your friends or some of the
other side the world yeah having a view
on what the creator is versus yours you
know exactly hundreds of gods let's say
exactly Bastian that's that's that's the
thing with me personally what is I
embarked on this journey so when I first
acknowledged that I must have a purpose
yeah then the question I was like what
is my purpose and who is my creator you
know that's the question that I would
ask myself by the way no just leave me
no worries I'll just Park up if you guys
yeah so basically the when it comes down
to is for example I do not believe in
religion therefore our religion or
man-made to control the masses etc yeah
but when you believe it in high
intelligence by default you have to
believe that he must have some kind of
communicate like something for us to get
to know him Jimmy who is he and what I
mean he's a male so you know yeah what
is that something what's it want from us
because when we buy a product it always
comes with a menu it tells you how to
use a product what to do with it what
not to do that you can translate so as
human beings I for you know if God
exists you know a create exists you know
he would want what's best for us and he
will tell us how to live our lives so
that's what I embarked on my journey and
said there is a religion that's the
truth
but which religion is
which religion is it so I I didn't know
a lot of Christianity you look at Islam
I looked into the Old Testament they
were Sikhism there must be some higher
intelligence something exactly this I do
which one do you go for exactly with me
personally for one money always like
ever the wrong you exactly meet me
personally me personally it's like i-i-i
had a criteria for myself yeah I said if
there's any scripture that I'm gonna
accept as a criteria it should not be
changed you should have some kind of
like something in Miracles whatever it
may be that I can you know understand
now with I found that with the Quran why
do I find out the Quran because it was
the only scripture that hasn't been
altered has not been changed it's still
preserved the only that millions of
people have memorize you have little
kids of memorized the entire Quran and
also it talks about that historical
miracles it talks about you know the you
know the Pharaoh
if you look into it like for example
historical miracles linguistic miracle
scientific miracles when I'm insensitive
miracles it talks about the embryo or
like the development of the development
of the for example that how
was it developed so the thing is with me
that was the only scripture that stand
stood out for me because when you look
into the Bible without an offense to the
Christians of course it's been changes
been corrupted if you look into the Old
Testament
it has men men have played a role in it
um translated and with Islam
we don't believe they're like separate
religions what we believe is they were
sent down from the same creator yeah so
the way to know we don't see this one
there's different religions there now
they've become different but it's the
same message all in like previous times
sent to different nations at different
times so it's like you have the Old
Testament you have the New Testament and
the Quran is a final Testament so we we
as Muslims have to believe in Jesus in
Moses we need to believe in the yes yeah
we believe that so the thing is close
when it comes to that we create off the
way I believe I know it's because I
believe the Quran has proven to me
because you'd have to look into it this
is just like it would not show yeah once
you acknowledge that then the question
comes to you is God because once you
establish an acknowledge that this book
is from God Almighty then whatever God
tells about himself then you accept that
because we don't believe God is a man
because we believe God is the most
powerful man is not meant I meant
I believe it's like exactly that's
that's one thing that I really liked
about them because in Christianity
believe God came down as a man and died
like okay God is the one who made us how
does he die well if he's a man yet he
eats food he eats food he has to go
toilet no how can I worship someone to
get I'm trying to say in that quantitate
Jesus wasn't God that was a was just
yeah some people if the Son of God
something is the perfect some somebody
is a part of God they actually believe
that yeah yeah but why would seems like
I watch some videos like I say before
check them out watching reality and like
if you have the chance you know